si no
ciao a tutti bentornati solito gialle
con vitale sempre più stefano chiesa
sempre challenge mai fatta prima d'ora e
cioè non pescare il palloncino sbagliato
perché in alcuni di questi paesi ci sono
ingredienti schifosi in crediti horror
in via trevi e ingredienti inquietanti
invece in alcuni ci sono bellissimi
ingredienti quindi noi diamo ovviamente
dovremo pescarli a occhi chiusi perché
abbiamo preparato noi ma io già non mi
dove stavano le cose schifose però
ripetiamo comunque occhi chiusi
poi alla fine de beer vi metto il
sondaggio qua e dovrete votare in base
conosciuto lo slime chi vince se vinco
io se vince vitale in base a quanto
siamo fortunati coloro cini speriamo il
meglio di solito lo so abbastanza
fortuna è vero mentre c'è tante cose
schifose educarte c'è ovviamente mi
raccomando lasciate un bel laica questo
video e se volete
la specializzazione e preparate
istituire vedere vi fate seppure sapere
nei commenti quali altre sale se volete
che facciamo assieme le più belle
mettere un cuoricino e andremo a farle
ora siete pronti mettetevi comodi
impastati di pop corn e iniziamo subito
allora in questi valori non c'è la colla
perché sono più che altre tutte e
decorazioni o cose strane
quindi andiamo innanzitutto a mettere la
colla del nostro secchiello ecco fatto
sia abbastanza grande
ok inizio io chiude gli occhi aspettano
ma mi chiami ricorda un cammino sceglie
adesso questa figura perché chi perché
siamo a mentre va assolutamente no però
lo vedo di holloween ma io propongo
ve l'ho detto io da quando ero piccolo
ho paura dei palloncini che scoppiano
quindi così che facciamo il pupillo ma
anche quindi commenti mi avevate scritto
che anche per alcuni di voi hanno questa
paura si vede telescopio può essere
ragazzi di un like di supporto per la
mia paura dei palloncini
[Musica]
non riesco vulcano non mercone anche
come facevo prima
ma scusa
ma non è possibile sono dei palloncini
riserve già successe quel palloncino non
è scoppiato lo teneva cassata addio cosa
c'era dentro ma che è bus sembra push
bianco no maggiore che schifo è un ragno
verde con il bus giallo sembra che sia
nato dall uovo tipo
mamma mia ovviamente dovevo essere la
più sfigata e beccare il peggiore cioè
bene so già che il mio slide sia
bellissimo ma cosa c'è qua ci sono degli
occhi si vedono il fatto che c è la mia
solita fortuna forato a capitare che gli
occhi aspetta aspetta
pesca non solo scegliere però è questo
lo può dare
ok dallo scoppio
[Musica]
ma come un circo che ha fatto cilecca
dovrei comprate non ci credo sbaglia
[Musica]
secondo mezzo al marasma che hai scelto
non so neanche che guerriero ad occhi
chiusi posso lo faccio bellissimi bello
invece io son ragno tifoso con gli occhi
e ictus
spetta che lo giro
attacco le sedi
ok oddio kifap3 arisa cosa sembra verde
le montagne e rumori strani questo penso
che vada perché un palloncino del tutto
diverso ambiti mai esploso tutto
[Musica]
scontato dappertutto almeno mi è
capitato qualcosa di buono
sono i diamantini con il blu dentro ce
ne sono tantissimi anche se non so che
effetto facciano questi diamanti con un
ragno i gialloblù che colore diventa
verde ci credo
novo seriamente 20 non ci porta la male
crowe e trazione la maledizione sempre
non è possibile gli umani è il mio slime
ovviamente fed e scommetto prima avevate
previsto anche poiché sarebbe diventato
perde ma possa anche vincere allora
magari hai capito un altro colore dopo
che gli occhi
cerca arancione cosa ci sta dentro non
riesco a capire
secondo me ci sta bene con la coppia
scoppia si sta copiando sono capitate le
palline con i glitter verdi ma restano
comunque più belle nel mio ragno lo
trasparente con i glitter e le palline
bianche che
ok tocca a me dalla finora bassi diciamo
che è abbastanza semplice è non temo per
il mio migliore ma so che si è fatto
alle mani
ecco il fatto e resterà un pò colorante
a me da f cell aspetta che gli spostiamo
con le sceglie questo giallo
oddio sembra un po strano dentro a un
colore molto strano vedo colore rosso
tante cose colorate o ci sono c'è un
sangue sembra sembra veramente lo stand
di halloween di già con la rossa con con
la glitterata e basta mi sembra con la
rossa e colla glitterata quindi fianco
lo re
oddio è un intruglio orrendo si vedono
anche gli occhi beh finora non c'è
trucco lo è però almeno si sono dei
glitter in più almeno mamma mio
personaggio mi po troppo denso di lei
che un po così e così e poi andiamo a
vedere l'ultimo ma non e mezzo momenti
che fino a quando in giro brutto adesso
è che bello che però aspetta
non sto per fare danni no mai
[Musica]
a e pescato la vescica
ma questo temporali con una vescica
guardate dentro mela verde chiama che si
rompe questo lo vedo molto pericolante
l'antica non ci sembra una bomba d'acqua
tipo anno questo gesto maldestro giovani
non trova aiuto questo esplode proprio
non paura dice addio esploderà
ma no ma come addio sta nascendo liquido
verde non so come non sia capitato a me
che io grassi ma pensavo hai capito se
anche questa sempre gelatinoso credo
siano
c'è la neve finta li più il verde
l'acqua ha ora si rovinerà anche il tour
live in effetti è diventato una palude
adesso a tanti dei tuoi followers piace
il verde quindi magari voteranno per me
perché comunque trasparente cicli è
purtroppo il mio ragni e mezzo per loro
vita completamente guarda ti dirò con
questo tocco di verde anche più bello
astri ci vedremo una volta che lo
abbiamo attivato mancano solo due fallon
si aspetta dalle celle uno dei
bellissimo
non lo so ma è verde il che non vi
convince qui è bellissimo quest esplode
[Musica]
si è scelta barba con un po d'acqua
c'era per farlo crescere a vediamo ti
cambia colore diventa azione magari
oddio sarà oddio è stranissimo ha detto
la consistenza di questo slide però è
meno sta diventando celeste importante
che sparisca ragno ma è ancora liberty
vastissimo però il colore è diventato
celeste al contrario del tuo vero ma è
una supposizione il colorante nero ed è
una cosa e sud ma cosa è successo
l'ultimo un palloncino non c'è bisogno
che chiude gli occhi perché l'ultimo
rimasto molto triste dal miglior nero
colorante non era verde casa esistere a
linden tra non lo so ma qualcosa di
brutto però fanno esplodere però quindi
magari ci proveremo con stop sotto devi
fare anche da sotto c'è qua dentro
sarebbe una cosa molto duro ma che cos'è
la melma tipo nome ricordiamo che sono
troppo o mio dio sono i pon pon con il
colorante nero e sembra tipo melma
sembra una cosa schifosa il controllo
che il ragno premium colore molto più
bella del 10 questo è nero via mail ma
vediamo ora che l'ottimismo magari esce
un galaxys line
ok andiamo ad attivare lo slime ma
soprattutto si attiverà questo slam
perché è un super strano è pieno d'acqua
mi fa sempre con formazione di mario
simile che se soggetti molto meno
neanche messo più in carbonato c'è
qualcosa di strada in questo slime è
verde il turno si sta attivando si è
rimasta nera o meno questa zuppa di
petrolio
ok ragazzi eccolo qua questo è il mio
sliven non so perché mi si sta pescando
allen che sono le unghie proprio fatto
lo smalto da poco comunque per fortuna e
cerete e non è diventato verde vediamo
se riuscite a individuare dopo il ragno
allora la consistenza è molto flessibile
[Musica]
un po cicli forse no non tanto però c'è
un bel po di acqua quindi è molto
stretti vedete
è uscito abbastanza grave alla fine il
colore è una sorta di celestino si sono
anche i glitter e per fortuna non si
vede molto bene il ragno è nemmeno gli
occhi ma vediamo se riuscite a vedere
dov'è e questi sono i suoni di tale sta
guardando con invidia il booking
[Musica]
quindi date un voto da 1 a 10 per
aspetto e persone as mr vediamo ora
quello di vita allora visto così sembra
anche bottino però ricordate che bei
riflessi quasi un galaxy galaxy
bellissima guardata colore soprattutto è
vero allora diciamo che non è proprio
bellissimo magari aspettiamo un attimino
finché non finché non si schiarisce
perché c'è la colla trasparente e poi
vediamo però dai a parte scherzi cordate
che bei che bei riflessi molto belli
per il resto è un po un po di chili se
non può fare un po da tiger one un
pochettino ed un po igp un po giblin po
uno schifo e quindi guardiamo elastico
abbastanza elastico la solita dell'asti
cita la sede della specifica dei miei
slime il 2000 è però dai guardate alla
fine c'è pure queste decorazioni di
tanto carina tutti i letterini co
intorno quelli più grandi quelle più
piccoli da a delle belle sfumature alla
fine dai adesso passiamo al lato suoni
vediamo un attimino c'è un pon pon che è
diventato rosso sangue non so se si vede
un po king siamo
[Musica]
bellissimo però sì ci siamo poi adesso
sempre non per i suoni
ok non proprio non proprio dei soli
bellissimi velo guardata tutto
in compenso i colori sono meravigliose
che ha sfumature un galaxy mera
fantastico vero
ok allora votate mi raccomando guardate
quelle colore non quel banale li di quel
colore banale di anita guardate guardate
che io contemplo questo nero strepitoso
ok ragazzi votate sopportino per tutto
mi metto il sondaggio qua quindi
cliccate votasse se ho vinto io servizio
vitale in base allo slam e in base ai
sogni smr quale il mio molto più grande
però guarda perché il mio no tutto
appallottolato prima guerra che grande
mio possibile
bello grande o di chi e qui mi portate a
fosse visto che ha inquinato il mio sly
se qua il ragno non volersi mai votate
chi ha vinto e ora che lascia qua 4
caselline spiccare per vedere le nostre
altre challenge astiene i nostri video
divertenti nostris line che cazzo quella
che preferite in buona cosa